[Music]
TV partners in crime or in this case
crafts parks and recreational lawns Amy
Poehler and Nick Offerman are together
again and it seems all is fair in love
and DIY hi I'm Amy Poehler and I'm Nick
Offerman welcome to making it these two
close friends start on Parks and
Recreation for seven seasons now they're
reunited hosting the new crafting
competition show think Project Runway
but with drills and hot glue buns Nick
and I have always been trying to find
ways just to get to see each other let's
celebrate and that is the sound fruit
for those that is the sound of wood
being you know Sean's sown Sean that's a
real hammer that was not a hammer effect
Nick who is married to Will and Grace
star Megan Mullally is an accomplished
woodworker
but Amy admits she's no Martha Stewart
decoupage is glue the contestants are
all amateur do-it-yourselfers competing
for a $100,000 prize nobody wins a
million dollars there might be some
secret surprises let's just say if you
win this show you'll never pay for hot
glue sticks again
[Music]